[Música]
Rusia vuelve a bombardear masivamente
Ucrania las autoridades de kiev
denuncian que este martes el ejército
ruso lanzó un centenar de misiles sobre
todo el territorio ucraniano los ataques
sobre infraestructura energética causan
apagones en todo el país
las 20 potencias del planeta se reúnen
en Indonesia en la Cumbre del g20 la
invasión rusa de Ucrania y los impactos
del conflicto sobre la economía global
marcan la agenda impulsada por
Washington
Este martes 15 de noviembre de 2022 la
humanidad alcanzó los 8.000 millones de
personas con enormes retos para nuestra
especie el mayor de todos combatir las
desigualdades materiales de derechos y
de oportunidades que marcan nuestras
vidas en función del lugar del mundo en
el que nacemos tendremos análisis en
esta emisión
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
Rusia volvió a bombardear todo el
territorio ucraniano kiev asegura que
Rusia lanzó Este martes un centenar de
misiles provocando apagones a lo largo y
ancho del país las autoridades
ucranianas alertan que la situación
energética es crítica a raíz de la ola
de ataques especialmente en las regiones
Norte y central en la capital los
bombardeos impactaron sobre un edificio
Residencial y al momento se reporta un
fallecido recordemos que ayer la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas
resolvió que Rusia deberá pagar la
reconstrucción del sur ucraniano
escuchemos al presidente vuelo de lensky
se lanzaron 85 ataques con misiles
contra contra nuestras ciudades
principalmente en la infraestructura
energética está claro lo que quiere el
enemigo no logrará su objetivo todavía
pueden haber alrededor de 20 ataques
Porvenir por lo que les pido a todos que
se cuiden y permanezcan en los refugios
por un tiempo sé que los ataques
cortaron el suministro eléctrico en
muchas ciudades de nuestro país estamos
trabajando restauraremos todo
sobreviviremos a todo Gloria a Ucrania
lo estás haciendo muy bien
Vamos ahora a Indonesia porque en Bali
empezó oficialmente la Cumbre del g20
los representantes de los 20 países más
ricos del mundo trabajan en una
declaración conjunta en el borrador la
mayoría de Estados condenan la invasión
rusa de Ucrania sin embargo el texto
refleja las distintas posiciones entre
los miembros del grupo entre los cuales
se encuentran Estados Unidos India y
China así como Rusia
vale Indonesia fue el destino del g20 la
reunión de los líderes de las
principales economías del mundo en la
agenda de la primera jornada un tema
opaco a los demás la guerra en Ucrania
presente hasta en el discurso inaugural
bien
ser responsable Aquí también significa
que debemos terminar la guerra
si la guerra no ha terminado será
difícil que el mundo avance
Y es que la mayoría de los países
asistentes como Estados Unidos o Francia
firmarán una declaración conjunta de
condena de la Guerra de Ucrania un tema
que preocupa a todos los invitados en
una ocasión en la que el presidente de
Ucrania voló zelenski ha aprovechado
para pedir que las naciones del g20
apoyen su plan para acabar con el
conflicto con propuestas como la
creación de un tribunal especial para
condenar la agresión de Rusia que está
reconozca la integridad territorial de
Ucrania o el intercambio total de
prisioneros y habló de un g-19 en una
Clara exclusión de Rusia
estoy convencido de que ahora es el
momento de que la guerra destructiva
rusa debe y pueda detenerse
algo que Rusia representada por el
canciller ser gay en la brop en la
Cumbre interpretó como la negativa de
Ucrania al inicio de las negociaciones
todos los problemas están en la parte
ucraniana que se niega categóricamente a
mantener cualquier conversación y viene
con condiciones obviamente reales e
inadecuadas para esta situación
[Música]
una situación que se ve con preocupación
desde el g20 que ya ha asegurado va a
firmar una declaración de condena de
cualquier amenaza de uso de armas
nucleares por parte de cualquier bando
en Irán Mañana se cumplen dos meses de
la muerte de maxa Mini bajo custodia de
la policía de la moral Este martes
empezó una huelga de tres días que a una
el movimiento desatado por la muerte de
la joven kurdo iraní con la
conmemoración de las protestas masivas
de 2019 en las que la fuerza pública
también mató a cientos de personas
nuestra corresponsal Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos amplía desde Teherán
esta huelga nacional que ha sido
convocada por tres días y que comenzó
hoy no solamente está llamada a recordar
a maxam Y esa joven kurda que hace ya
dos meses fue detenida por la policía la
moral y dos días después falleció en un
hospital de Teherán sino especialmente
para recordar a miles de personas que
hace tres años en el 2019 en esta misma
fecha en el mes de avant como se conoce
por el calendario persa salieron a
protestar por el aumento repentino del
precio de la gasolina y En aquel momento
la represión si bien no se sabe si fue
mayor si fue mucho más concentrada en
pocos días y bastante violenta algunas
versiones hablan de más de 300
fallecidos y otras como la que citó la
agencia de noticias routers que hablaba
con Fuentes gubernamentales locales
gente que habló fuera of the récord
hablaba de 1500 muertos en aquel momento
así que querían recordar a estas
personas estuvimos dando vueltas por
Teherán y vivimos parte de los sectores
comerciales parcialmente cerrados
también veíamos mucha gente caminando en
la calle intentando unirse y cuando se
unían pues cantaban esos eslóganes que
se han convertido en símbolos de estas
protestas incluido muerte al dictador y
también veíamos muchas mujeres sin el
velo como acto de protesta y está huelga
es importante para quienes están en las
calles Desde hace dos meses porque una
de las críticas que hacían al sector
económico es que no se habían arriesgado
a apoyar estas protestas la indignación
cada vez es mayor la rabia es cada vez
mayor pero muchas personas se preguntan
Cómo poner en riesgo sus negocios o su
vida económica por algo que no saben qué
va a pasar así que para quienes
protestan lo que sucedió hoy ha sido
bastante importante
Israel no va a colaborar con la
investigación del FBI sobre el asesinato
de la periodista de aljazzira sherine
abouagle recordemos que distintas
investigaciones independientes han
señalado que la bala que mató a la
reportera Palestina estadounidense fue
disparada por un soldado israelí en la
cisjordania ocupada en mayo los detalles
los tiene nuestro corresponsal en
Jerusalén Federico cuévar verena la
decisión de Estados Unidos iniciaron una
nueva investigación sobre el asesinato
de girina buacle ha sacudido la ferias
relaciones que mantiene con Israel
Aunque ni el departamento de Justicia ni
el FBI han brindado confirmaciones ni
detalles sobre ella el gobierno interino
de Israel ya salió al cruce de la
pesquisa que fue informada por primera
vez por el medio estadounidense político
el ministro de defensa benigans en la
calificó de grave error y anticipó que
Israel no cooperará a la vez que
defendió los resultados de la
investigación interna de las fuerzas
israelíes esta en septiembre
predeterminado que era probable que por
error un soldado israelí haya asesinado
Angelina bucle durante la redada de las
fuerzas israelíes en jenning ocupada el
11 de mayo pasado pero Israel no ha
determinado responsabilidades y se ha
negado a abrir una investigación
criminal la decisión también significa
un giro en la en la política de Estados
Unidos que hasta aquí se había
conformado con las explicaciones
israelíes Y ese también un movimiento
muy poco habitual porque se trata de una
investigación que involucra a uno de sus
aliados más fuertes y que pone en
cuestión el discurso habitual de Israel
que defiende el accionar de sus soldados
en los territorios ocupados la familia
de chirina bucle que durante meses ha
abogado por un mayor involucramiento del
gobierno de Joe biden ha calificado a la
investigación como un paso importante y
pidió que Estados Unidos utilice todas
las herramientas a su alcance para
encontrar respuestas y determinar
responsabilidades cabe recordar que
investigaciones independientes de medios
y declaraciones de Testigos presenciales
han rechazado las alegaciones desde que
en el momento de la muerte de abogacle
había fuego palestino y además la
periodista asesinada se encontraba
correctamente identificada con un
chaleco y un casco con la leyenda de
prensa vamos con noticias de Estados
Unidos porque carry Lake una de las
candidatas republicanas de más alto
perfil en las elecciones de medio
término Y quién abrazó Las falsas
afirmaciones de fraude electoral del ex
presidente Donald Trump en 2020 perdió
la carrera por la gobernación de Arizona
la reñida contienda por la gobernación
entre la republicana Cari Lake y la
demócrata Katie hopes fue una de las más
significativas ya que Arizona fue un
estado clave en las elecciones de 2020 y
se espera que también lo sea en las de
2024 la derrota de la repúblicana Se
confirmó justo en el día en el que
Donald Trump tiene previsto hacer un
importante anuncio desde su residencia
de mar al lago se especula sobre su
candidatura a las presidenciales de 2024
vamos ahora a Colombia Porque los
primeros pasos hacia su promesa de paz
total la aprobación de la Reforma
tributaria y sus esfuerzos por retomar
las relaciones con Venezuela marcaron
los primeros 100 días del gobierno del
izquierdista Gustavo Petro en la
presidencia unos actos que definen el
tono de su gobierno pero que plantean
enormes desafíos el informe es de
Manuela cano;
hace 100 días Colombia recibía el primer
presidente izquierdista de la historia
del país Gustavo Petro llegaba con la
promesa de cambio poco tiempo después el
nuevo mandatario hacía un primer paso
para cumplir con el principal eje de su
campaña presidencial sancionar la ley de
paz total abriendo la posibilidad de
negociar con grupos guerrilleros como el
ejército de liberación nacional o las
disidencias de las FARC
una firma cargada de significado pero
que no deja de plantear dudas y desafíos
como explicó Néstor rosanía para Franz
24 Hay que hacerlo pero no se va a
lograr porque de las disidencias de las
fallamos en la segunda o hasta en la
tercera generación lo mismo pasó hace
más de 30 años con el Cartel de Cali El
Cartel de Cali negocio con el gobierno y
apareció el cartel del Norte del Valle y
una nueva espiral de la violencia otro
triunfo del nuevo gobierno fue la
aprobación en el congreso de la Reforma
tributaria que busca generar justicia
social Aunque impone más impuestos a las
personas más ricas del país Peter tuvo
que renunciar a puntos como grabar las
pensiones elevadas esta protesta
nosotros la realizamos porque estamos en
contra de este gobierno de izquierda que
se eligió no estamos de acuerdo con las
reformas que están haciendo y el plano
internacional el presidente se apresuró
para cambiar de tono en las relaciones
con Venezuela
abriendo la frontera terrestre con el
país vecino un acto simbólico que sigue
teniendo grandes pendientes logísticos y
prácticos pero celebrado por el
mandatario y es un día histórico
para la región para el país para América
del Sur después de 100 días Pedro tras o
con firmeza Los Caminos de su agenda la
gran pregunta que muchos se plantean es
como los encaminará a sus objetivos
finales y en medio de las preocupaciones
climáticas globales nuevamente
activistas intentan llamar la atención
sobre la emergencia planetaria lanzando
pinturas sobre obras de arte esta vez el
escenario de la acción fue el museo
leopold de Viena Austria los activistas
del grupo Last Generations echaron
pintura negra sobre la obra muerte y
vida de gustav klimt y pegaron sus manos
al vidrio que protege el cuadro los
activistas detenidos por las autoridades
pedían detener los proyectos de
exploración de gas y petróleo que
dijeron son una sentencia de muerte para
la humanidad
[Música]
según las proyecciones de Naciones
Unidas hoy martes 15 de noviembre de
2022 ya somos 8 mil millones de personas
las que habitamos la tierra el mayor
reto para la humanidad es combatir las
injusticias que marcan el desarrollo de
nuestras vidas en función del lugar del
mundo en el que nacemos desigualdades
materiales de acceso a recursos a
oportunidades de derechos y de impacto
de la crisis climática sobre nuestros
hogares
un nuevo hito para la humanidad Este
martes nació en República Dominicana
Damián que Naciones Unidas considera el
habitante número 8.000 millones una
celebración de la diversidad para la ONU
pero con advertencias lo recién llegados
a la tierra encuentran un planeta en
emergencia miles de millones de personas
están luchando cientos de millones se
enfrentan al hambre e incluso a la
hambruna números
récord de estar en movimiento en busca
de y alivio de la deuda y las
dificultades Las Guerras y los desastres
climáticos en 2023 India superará a
China como el país más poblado el
gigante asiático se enfrenta a un grave
declive de su tasa de natalidad y más de
la mitad del aumento de la población se
concentrará principalmente en África
concretamente Las Naciones subsaharianas
contribuirán con más de la mitad del
crecimiento de la población mundial
previsto hasta 2050 en Nigeria por
ejemplo la Edad Media es de 17 años
la creciente población en Nigeria se
debe a que no controlamos nuestra tasa
de crecimiento
si miras al norte son libres de casarse
con hasta cuatro esposas y cada esposa
puede tener tantos hijos como quiera
desde el sur sabemos que por las
dificultades económicas la gente tiende
a no tener demasiados hijos
el estudio de la ONU también refleja que
para 2050 habrá un 10% más de personas
mayores de 65 años con fuertes impactos
en Europa
somos 8 mil millones pero en nuestro
país Italia el crecimiento es cero nos
creemos que los jóvenes de hoy ya no
pueden formar una familia por una serie
de problemas con un crecimiento
ralentizado desde 1950 se espera que
2080 sea la década en la que el mundo
alcance su pico de habitantes con más de
10.400 millones de personas en la
actualidad dos tercios de la población
mundial vive en un país o área donde la
fecundidad es inferior a 2,1 nacimientos
por mujer el nivel considerado óptimo
para garantizar El reemplazo
generacional